let's bring in tommy lahren out kick
host joins us now tommy what do you make
of this executive order governor abbott
says he's forced to do things like this
because president biden isn't doing his
job
well that's exactly right if the biden
administration isn't going to do their
job to secure our border then it's going
to be up to governors like abbott to do
something we know the abbott has taken a
strong leadership role in this as of
other governors like ron desantis and
that's what it's going to take but
listen there is no excuse for what is
going on at our southern border
absolutely no excuse and we haven't
heard the biden administration even
tried to give us one but the fact of the
matter is not only is what's going on at
our border not only is it cheating
americans who are being inundated by
illegal immigrants into their
communities not just on the border but
elsewhere it's sliding the very migrants
that are coming over who will never live
the american dream because of the way
that they entered illegally but also as
governor abbott said this is in not only
embolding but enriching the criminal
organizations the coyotes the drug
cartels that are not only ravaging their
home countries but are ravaging ours
with the opioid epidemic the fentanyl
coming across into our country deadly in
our streets there is no excuse for it
and even worse as i said the biden
administration our borders are kamala
they haven't even tried to offer us one
they've remained silent on this issue
unacceptable they need to be pressed on
this on a daily basis did happen go far
enough
i think he's doing everything that he
possibly can listen i think that the
people of texas are even leaning on him
more so for leadership because they know
that they're not going to get any
leadership out of this white house but
it's also up to congress to be vocal
about this as well this is a national
security issue and our governor
shouldn't be left to have to deal with
this but unfortunately that's the
situation that they're dealing with and
i hope that more governors stand up next
to abbott and and with his same resolve
and have similar solutions to his
someone has to do something because this
is not sustainable you know tommy i
would understand president biden's
border policies if it were working for
him politically but you have this
historically blue congressional seat in
texas
flip red largely because of the open
border issue and yet the president still
isn't reversing course
yeah that's because democrats play the
long game here they're okay with losing
a few seats here and there they're okay
with the narrative around the country
being unhappy with the border crisis the
invasion which is what it truly is
they're okay with that because they're
interested in the long game and the long
game means more voters for them or so
they think so they're going to remain
quiet on this the numbers don't lie
we're having hundreds of thousands of
people come into our country and those
are the ones that have been apprehended
that does not include the godaways so
there's no other excuse for there's no
other rationale for it other than the
democrats see new voters coming in and
that's why they're allowing this to
continue to happen
make sure to check out tommy larry is
fearless airing live on mondays
wednesdays and thursdays on out kick and
it needs to be pointed out that tommy
tuesday is here on friday i know it's
very obvious but that's what i do i
point out the obvious tommy lahren we
appreciate your time as always thank you
my friend
i'm steve ducey i'm brian killme and i'm
ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis